was passiert wenn zzenmusik auf einer
Kaffeefahrt gespielt wird davon
berichten die zzen und es gibt einen
Schönheitswettbewerb Frauenarzt mit oder
ohne Sonnenbrille was steht in besser
schreibt es in die Kommentare und
ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran jetzt kommen die totalen verrückten
überlotto Fragen hier die Fragen der
Fragen im fragenag Fragenlotto aus dem
Fragenkatalog also ihr könnt so viel
ziehen wie ihr wollt die roten sind
unverschämte Fragen die Gr sind harmlose
Fragen ich finde unverschämte haben ja
ihr wollt immer wollen alle unverschämte
Fragen haben die sind persönlich auf
euch zugeschnitten kannst auch blind
rein aber wahrscheinlich du siehst ja
sowieso nie was doch doch ich se was
hast dich an die Dunkelheit gewöhnt
inzwischen ich habe keine unverschämte
Frage soll ich die vorlesen oder du nee
nee du liest die vor und beantwortest
sie auch willst du anfangen erstmal
damit ich mich konzentrieren kann
ma vorbereiten er will sich Frage
währenddessen
durchlesen wann schreibt endlich Texte
die man auch unter 3 Promille hören kann
also 3 Promille ist wirklich so krass
ich glaube bei dre Promille liege ich
komplett nicht mehr ansprechbar am
Strand am Ballermann und kann überhaupt
nichts mehr raffen also dre Promille ist
auf jeden Fall definitiv zu viel also
zwei drei Bierchen sagen wir mal ein
Promille aber im Endeffekt ist es
einfach so es kommt immer auch auf die
Laune drauf an im Endeffekt ist es
einfach so wie ist man gelaunt wie ist
man nicht gelaunt und so
aber
ich finde die Frage eigentlich irgendwie
ein bisschen doof natürlich die muss ja
doof sein sonst wä sie nicht rot es ist
ein Dis es ist einfach weiß du und das
ist ist ja auch das was bei arztmusik so
besonders ist es ist polarisierend
entweder Leute finden es geil oder sie
finden es scheiße und der Typ findet
halt unsere Musik kacke aber er brauch
auch nicht hören das ist so eine
Standardfrage die man immer wieder hört
und dann denkt man so h ist es jetzt
genau gemeint ja aber am Ende aber im
Endeffekt im Endeffekt im Endeffekt ist
es so dass die Leute trotzdem ist ist es
wie bei talking dier Bohen hat wollt
euch doch nicht mit diesen großen
Künstler ver nein pass mal auf pass mal
auf eine Sache er hat 80 Millionen CDs
verkauft das sagt er immer wieder und
die Leute geben es aber nicht zu aber
finden es gut und bei uns ist es genau
dasselbe die Leute finden es einfach gut
egal ob die besoffen sind nicht besoffen
sind oder was weiß ich genommen haben
und so es ist scheißegal die Musik die
wir machen macht Spaß und du musst dazu
nicht besoffen sein oder sonst irgendwas
mit dem promillees eigentlich komplett
ja aber okay für uns ist es doch super
im Endeffekt interessieren sich Leute
für uns und das macht also zzenmusik
macht einfach Spaß und drei Promille
oder vier Promille ich bin immer dabei
und so auch bei Null Promille kein
Problem alles super alles cool alles
bestens so pass auf mir ist jetzt noch
was eingefallen zu dem Thema von
unabhängig von aber es ist ein
bestimmter Stil in dem er das singt und
zwar den man oft im fußballstaden gehört
hört und ich kann das gar nicht
beschreiben was geht ab al ist so eine
das ist kommt von ganz unten weiß du was
ist weß was das sind kinderler das sind
kinderleder für Erwachsene und schreib
mal ein gutes Kinderlied schreib mal ein
gutes Kinderlied es schafft kein Mensch
es schafft kein Mensch bloß wir schaffen
es ist einfach so ja wenige wenige in
der Position wo wir sind das ist halt
total schwierig schreibt man ein
Kinderlied was Erwachsene gerne hören
wollen aber dazu muss ich auch noch mal
sagen wir haben ja ein Album gemacht
Teufelswerk das war auf unserer letzten
CD Party Chaos diese bonuscd und da
haben wir auch mit vielen Rockern
zusammenearbeitet mit Rockmusikern mit
wirklich sehr sehr sehr guten Musikern
und das haben Leute von den agebocks
waren damit am Start gewesen haben sich
das reingezogen die haben z.B die oder
hier auch von Tote Hosen kann man von
allen Seiten und die sagen das ist das
sind richtige Songs wenn man die als
Rocksongs hören klingen die schon mal
wieder ganz anders als wenn die halt so
elektronisch sind oder wenn man die halt
mit diesem Party Hintergrund sieht dann
sind es auf einmal richtig gute Songs
hörst du die ain auf einmal als Rocksong
an wird der Song zu einer Ballade weißt
du und du wunderst d denkst und die
sagen e das ist vom Songwriting oberste
Klasse so weiß du ich will uns jetzt W
jetzt eingebildet arrogant irgendwelche
Sachen reden aber es ist halt wirklich
so es ist ja natürlich man macht sich
Image natürlich auch ein bisschen selber
also wenn wir natürlich auf Mallorca
auftreten und so dann hat man natürlich
auch dieses Schlager und sufer image was
da natürlich auch mit beikommt finden
wir aber auch geil weil wir finden ja
alles geil also wir finden Rock geil wir
finden HipHop geil Schlager Techno find
mehr man sich damit beschäftigt umso
cooler findet man es auch also wir waren
mit vielen Leuten mit Journalisten und
so auch unterwegs und so die haben uns
kennengelernt genauso wie wir uns jetzt
kennenlerernen du
sagst mit nee mit den mit den kann man
sich ja unterhalten die sind ja
eigentlich ganz cool die können feiern
die sind die haben was die haben
wenigstens ein bisschen was in der Birne
und so und die sind cool warum nicht was
ich auch wenn ich jetzt hö
Zusammenarbeit mit Rockmusikern was ich
feststelle die die ihr Kollegen
untereinander habt ja eigentlich
überhaupt keine Vorbehalte also jetzt
z.B Haftbefehl auf dem Album ist ein
Feature mit Jan Delay ja das geil da
hätte man gesagt J und Haftbefehl
hä das wirlich wer hätte denn gedacht
die zzen und nener
ja absolut genau also unter Kollegen das
gibt's eigentlich gar nicht dass man
sagt was sind das für welche Musik
machen alle Musik wir machen nur Musik
würde ich auch sagen sehr schön jetzt
eine positive Frage wir kommen ja schon
posizenmik zzen Merchandising jetzten
Kodex euer Erfolg nimmt ja nicht ab
oder kann ich jetzt nicht wirklich sagen
also ich ist ist irgendwie
kontinuierlich sind wir erfolgreich wir
freuen uns darüber dass wir den Erfolg
haben und ja danke gut okay okay ja das
ist immer die Grünen Fragen sind auch am
schwierigen beantworten weiterziehen ja
pass auf also es gibt Leute die ziehen
ja alle Fragen geil alle aber ihr müsst
nicht alle ziehen weil dann bleibt immer
noch die Überraschung wel zwei
unangenehme ich freue mich h du
zuerst bei uns bei uns h djö ist ja
komplett dem haben wir eine ähnliche
Frage gestellt mit dem ohol der ist
komplett ausgetitcht der war stinksauer
sa der war stinksauer sauer also also
ganz ehrlich um mich sauer oder um um
uns beide sauer zu kriegen da da muss da
muss was ganz schlimmes passieren also
seid ihr ohne Sonnenbrille so hässlich
oder warum zieht ihr sie nie ab also bei
dir gilt es offensichtlich
nicht da kann jeder für sich selber also
im ffekt bin ich nicht aber im Endeffekt
ist es einfach so wir haben Logo das ist
eine Sonnenbrille
das gibt's einfach nicht wir haben da
eine Monopolstellung wir sind da hier
ich bin ohne Sonnenbrille er mit
manchmal ist er es ist immer
unterschiedlich ob ich hässlich bin oder
nicht ich weiß es nicht ich fühle mich
selber ja weiß ich nicht die Schönheit
kommt ja auch von
innen gerade gefeht nee aber aber es ist
ja auch so eine imageepfleg also im
Endeffekt meine Sonnenbrille nehme ich
fast nie ab also es ist auch so ein
bisschen so im ist auch so ein bisschen
es macht ein auch ein bisschen
interessant we die Leute haben so dieses
Bild von dir du bist halt so und die
freuen sich dann auch wenn ich mal ohne
Sonnenbrille sehen Brille bitte kommen
Brille und wie gesagt die Sonnenbrille
ist einfach so irgendwie zu unserem
markenzeichenter streicht die Coolheit
auch ein bisschen und der Vorteil ist
auf der Straße wird man nicht erkannt
wenn man entweder ohne Sonnenbrille
auftritt und mit Sonnenbrille auf der
Straße das ist nämlich gerade auch das
Ding also wenn man jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich ist bei money Mark der wird echt
öfter erkannt als ich weißt du also das
liegt auch daran wenn ich meine
Sonnenbrille und mein cy abnehme erkennt
mich kein Schwein niemand ich kann zu
McDonald's reingehen kann mir ein Burger
holen kann hier rum spazieren sonst was
mich erkennt keiner das ist ein bisschen
der Effekt wie mit Sido damals mit der
Maske als er seinen größten Erfolg hatte
wir kannten ja sino damals schon sehr
gut da habe ich ihm damals am kürsten
Damm getroffen er hatte gerade sein Hit
mein Blog am Start und die Leute haben
alle über sido gequatscht und er ist
über ein kudam gelaufen kein Schwein hat
ih erkannt niemand wusste dass er es ist
und so ist es bei mir auch ungefähr
jetzt gerade also ich kann wirklich
meine Sonnenbrille in cy abnehmen kein
Schwein erkennt mich ja sehr schön
nächste Frage nächste Frage ihr seid
doch zu alt für Partymusik oder also die
Frage
ist das da war ein seufer und das war
einer der nicht gerne feiert ja
genau also nee zu alt für Party ist man
glaube ich nie also Mann hat immer
irgendwie ein Grund zum Feier man kann
immer feiern und man feiert ja auch noch
wenn man älter ist irendwelche
seniorurage man feiert Hochzeiten man
feiert die Goldene Hochzeit man feiert
alles mögl W ich meine wie verbittert
muss man denn sein dass man so eine
Frage stellt also jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
weil im Endeffekt den ja zu alt wenn du
den buen wi Social Club anguckst wie alt
die Männer waren ja und die haben so
krass gefeiert die haben noch mal einen
zweiten Frühling gehabt die haben
wirklich die haben sich wirklich richtig
krass gefeiert oder ein Kumpel von uns
Frank [__] der ist Porno
stop nein der ist ein Pornodarsteller
von org ja und der hat gefeiert bis zum
geht nicht mehr noch mal und für den war
das wirklich geil also und der war
nichto war ist er verstorben oder was
nee der hat wieder aufgehört
damit zu viel glaube ich
okay aber so alt sind wir do noch gar
nichtage
Hall mit
23ote ja
genauotün ver die grün s aber langweilig
die sind natürlich lang alle ja genau ja
stimmt die gr wollt alle nehmen ja
logisch wirklich okay
gut ja wir haben so ein Keller bei uns
und da sind total frustrierte die machen
dieag warum tragt immer so bescheuer
Klamotten ich GLB sind Leute die
beschäftigen sich nicht oh Gott also im
Endeffekt warum bescheuerte Klamotten
das ist T-Shirt und Jeans da hat
Frauenarzt auch mal einen geilen Track
zugemacht wir tragen das worauf wir Bock
haben und gib komischen Mützen mit ja
ach so diese Mützen die na obenen in
rosa ich meine das ist schlimm aber das
trag nicht oder das ist durch ein Zufall
entstanden doch doch das tragen wir auch
manch aber dieses Capy was du jetzt
gerade angesprochen hast nach oben das
ist durch ein Zufall entstanden wir
haben ja das Video zu das geht
abgedrehen haben gesagt wir haben Partys
Song wir drehen daz ein Video das war ja
noch gar nicht absehbar dass das so ein
großer Erfolg wird und da hat ein Kumpel
von uns unser Merchandiser sogar
zufällig der Rave D hat ein cy aufgabt
was so nach oben war hier teilstanden
das ist ja auch so ein bisschen wir
unsere Musik ähnelt ja ein bisschen dem
80s wir haben ja auch so diesen 80s
Touch die ganze Zeit drin und auch
diesen 90s Trash Zeug und so und das
unterstreicht einfach auch noch mal die
Musikrichtung es passt einfach modisch
noch mal da zusammen undendwie und das
lustige ist dann haben die Leute
angefangen sich so zu kleiden wie im
Video wir waren das ja gar nicht also
die haben euch das ja die haben sich
dann darin orientiert und dadurch haben
sozusagen die zzen die die Musik gehört
haben haben das zu diesem Style gemacht
das waren ja damals sogar auch noch
hauptsächlich Leute die vorher unsere
alten Sachen gehört haben und das ist
irgendwie so ein fließender Übergang
gewesen deswegen passt es auch ganz cool
alles zusammen so also ich muss dazu
noch mal sagen generell es gibt keine
bescheuerten Klamotten das ist
eigentlich total doof ach quatsch
überhaupt nicht ja eben das ist dann
wieder eine Geschmackssache es gibt
keine bescheuerten K komm ich ich hab
eine karierte Hose und wenn ich die zum
Hemd anziehe sieh das dann ist das geil
dann ist das arschaffen Titten geil und
dann gewinnst du vielleicht auch noch
ein Preis ich wei aber aber das ist ja
stell vor jetzt kommt irgende sagt warum
trägst du im mal so bescheuerte karierte
Hemden was willst den darauf antworten
weißt du und und wie Mark schon gesagt
hat ich habe ein Song gemacht der heißt
T-Shirt und Jeans und der unterstreicht
auch die Attitüde es ist einfach so
weißt du egal wie viel Geld man macht
egal wie berühmt du bist oder sonst was
wenn du in ein Restaurant gehst fün
Sterne Restaurant dann musst du nicht
mit Anzug da reingehen du kannst auch so
reingehen wenn du dich so wohl fühlst
mit T-Shirt und Jeans dann wird dir das
jeder eher abnehmen als wenn du dich so
gezwungen im Anzug und auf
Schi muss sich woh ich find so diesen
Standard Style den alle tragen weißt du
wenn wirklich alle zu New Yorker gehen
alle zu H&M und alle zu C&A und alle
tragen immer die gleichen Klamotten das
finde ich viel bescheuerter ich finde
wenn man individuell ist so wie es in
der hiphopszene ist man kann es ja auch
mischen New Yorker H&M man kann es ja
auch
alles genau man nimmt von irgendwas
alles so oder das geilste ist was wir
auch mal als zzten sagen was auch viele
machen bei unseren Konzerten die machen
sich ihre Klamotten selber die machen
sich wirklich ihre Klamotten selber und
das kommt eigentlich auch aus der
hiph-hopszene damit haben sich die Leute
ihre Jacken selber besprüht haben sich
backpieces hinten drauf gemacht die sind
einfach sehr kreativ gewesen was so den
Style anging und das wollten wir mit
atzmusik auchwie wieder schaffen und so
das T-Shirt ist übrigens ein Original
90er Jahr Shirt sieht jetzt nicht
besonders aus aber ich will auch eine
Message rüberbringen ich will sagen save
the nature man denk mal an die t und
kann das mit meinem kann das mit meinem
T-Shirt ausdrücken das ist doch nicht
bekloppt man alter das ist doch nicht
bekloppt aber die ist ist ja auch eine
unverschämte Frage ich hab noch eine
also die hast du nicht beantwortet ja
ich weiß gar nicht was hier steht wie
habt ihr es geschafft dass jeder ein
Atze sein
will ja das ist das weiß ich auch
nicht ich glaube das hängt auch wieder
mit der Identifikation zusammen dass die
Leute sich damit identifizieren konnen
mit der zzenutenz mit
derzenutenz gut das ist gut ja wirklich
weil das ist was Eigenes das war
irgendwie es hat auch ein bisschen alles
es passt in die Zeit gerade rein es ist
so alles ist mies alles ist grau alles
ist fies es ist Wirtschaftskrise da sind
Kriege da ist dies und das und dann
braucht man auch einfach mal ein
Wochenend an dem man abschalten kann
oder wo man sagen kann auf dem
Nachmittag ey heute scheiß ich mal auf
alles und ich bin Atze und ich fick da
einfach drauf und ma einfach worauf ich
Bock habe und das das fehlt den Leuten
glaube ich auch oft dass die einfach so
sind wie sie sind dass sie so sein wie
sie sind weil auf Arbeit vor ihrem Chef
oder in der Schule oder so da müssen sie
irgendwie anders sein vielleicht auch
vor ihren Eltern oder vor Freunden und
da haben sie irgendwie alle die Freiheit
so zu sein wie sie wollen und einfach
mal die Sau rauszulassen einfach ja ich
bin halt ein AR ne ne ich glaube das ist
auch eine wichtige Botschaft den Leuten
zu sagen sei wie du du bist weil aus
also was man dazu sagen muss ist auch
wirklich wir haben ja auch auf unseren
Konzerten wirklich das habe ich auchi
glaube ich auch bei klickon bei euch bei
dir bei irgendeinem Rapper auch in
Interview gehört und bei uns ist es
genau dasselbe dass wirklich egal woher
du kommst egal ob du lange Haare hast
kurze Haare hast ob du eine Brille hast
ob du Pickel hast oder ob du groß klein
dick dünn oder so bist ob du krank bist
oder nicht krank bist und so alle feiern
in dem Moment zusammen und sind einfach
glücklich und froh und in den zwei
Stunden fangen Leute einfach an zu
lachen und es ist auch wirklich
teilweise so es geht wirklich so krass
das ist fast gar nicht mehr lustig aber
es ist trotzdem eine gute Sache das
wirklich sehr kranke Menschen die im
Rollstuhl sind oder wirklich eine
schwere Krankheit haben denn zu uns auch
im Backstage kommen oder die wir denn
wirklich sagen e der kommt jetzt mit auf
die Bühne und wir feiern zwei Stunden
einfach mit dem ab ja egal was der für
eine Krankheit hatte und wir unterhalten
uns auch dann mit demjenigen und
verbringen eine gewisse Zeit mit ihm
machen Fotos und so wo den Freunde und
Eltern und Bekannte kommen ey mein Sohn
oder mein mein Freund oder mein was weiß
ich hat in den zwei Stunden seit 6
Jahren nicht so gelacht und das haben
wir ganz oft gehabt und so und das ist
eine ganz wichtige Sache ich glaube so
dieses Glück und diese Freude und dieser
Spaß am Leben sollte man immer
beibehalten man muss Kind im Herzen
bleiben und so und auch Spaß einfach an
der an der ganzen Sache haben ja und
egal wie weit es irgendwie austickt oder
ob Leute sagen nee das ist alles scheiße
das ist mir zu doof und
bla
ja das ist halt ein Punkt der ist glaube
ich ganz wichtig im Leben auch das muss
das muss man mal unterstreichen ja und
das ist bei uns bei jedem Konzert dazu
und das da kann ich Brief und Siegel das
kann auch jeder hier ob
unser Manager hier Stefan oder frauenatz
alle können es unterschreiben es gibt
ganz viele Gruppierungen die sich
wirklich treffen und zu unseren
Konzerten kommen und wirklich Scheiße im
Leben erlebt haben und so und zu uns
kommen und richtig Power geben und Party
machen und so weiter und so fort ja
super und das sind auch nicht Leute die
nur zzmusik hören das sind ja Leute die
hören was ganz anderes die hören
vielleicht Rap den ganzen Tag sind nur
auf HipHop oder es gibt auch Leute die
nur Rock hören oder so und deswegen es
ist sehr Generation übergreifend und
auch gen übergreifend musikgen
übergreifend Musik dann nimmst du den
wir tauschen die okay hier aber
eigentlich müsste
das Frauenarzt wann lernst du endlich zu
rappen was soll man dazu sagen also
ja du kannst sagen nie oder ich kann
rappen oder was ja es ist auch immer
Ansichtssache also ich meine im
Endeffekt den Takt trifft man und Reime
hat man auch und es ist auch immer eine
Sache des Willens ne also wenn ich will
kann ich auch Doppelreime machen ich
kann auch flexen oder sonst was aber
vielleicht habe ich gar keinen Bock
drauf vielleicht habe ich einfach mein
Stil gefunden und finde den geil so wie
er ist ich bin auch ein Fan von Cool Mod
z.B wenn man sich seine Scheiben anhört
dann muss man manchmal lachen wie bin
ich da rappt und er ist trotzdem für
mich der King und meiner Meinung hat er
damals runy MC im Battle weggeburnt ist
einfach so und das ist einfach
Geschmacksfrage und und ich ich bin auch
ein Fan von von Rappern die die
teilweise ich ich meine z.B K1 ich finde
K1 super gut ich bin ein riesen K1 Fan
und ich weiß dass er einfach schnell
rappen kann er kann flexen sonst was
aber ich finde den Style den er jetzt
gefunden hat wie er jetzt rappt wo er
langsam und gechillt rappt finde ich
geiler ich finde ich hör mir jetzt
einfach lieber an das ist einfach cooler
und ja so ist es mit mir wahrscheinlich
auch ich habe einfach mein Stil gefunden
den die Leute cool finden damit bin ich
erfolgreich und genau wie beim money
Mark ich finde auch manchmal die Reime
die sich nicht reimen finde ich manchmal
die besten von ihm ich muss sich auch
nicht reimen also nee es muss sich nicht
reimen unreime
Reime unreime Reime nein pass auf man
hört ja oft nicht hin und bei Haftbefehl
wenn mir einer gesagt h wieso ist reimt
sich ja gar nicht echt reimt sich nicht
was stimmt da sind ja nicht immer Reime
und
ja es ist Geschmacksfrage also muss
immer sagen ich könnte jetzt auch andere
Rapper dissen mache ich aber nicht ich
lass Namen immer weg aber mir gefallen
Rapper die hochkaretig in die in den
Himmel gelobt werden weil sie so toll
Rappen finde ich teilweise richtig
schlecht wo ich mir denke e das ist
nicht gut lang ist ist halt
Geschmacksfrage es ist wirklich eine
Geschmacksfrage weiß du wird ein Curse
beispielsweise wird absolut gefeiert als
ein riesen krasser Rapper aber ich sage
es gibt Rapper die 1us mal geiler sind
wie Orgi z.B oder Prinz P boxstar oder
sonst was die ich einfach besser finden
aber das ist halt auch Geschmacksfrage
ne okay gut jetzt zum Abschluss eine
grüne Frage warum funktioniert keine
Party ohne atzenmusik ich denke mal dass
atzenmusik wir haben wirklich da
irgendwie was da ist irgendwas zustande
gekommen ja wo die Leute was neues
einfach hören auf jeder Party und
da irgendwelche bessse um die Ohren
gefeuert kriegen irgendwelche
verrückten Wörter ich meine das geht ab
und discog spricht für sich irgendwie
das das läuft ja sogar auf ähäh wo waren
wir auf in un zum Hotel da waren ganz
viele Rentner das war so eine
Kaffeefahrt da sind wir eingecheckt das
ist keine Lüge da sind wir eingecheckt
und da sind wirklich da lief dann auf
einmal erst irgendwas ich weiß irgendein
irgendein schlagerlied und und danach
kam das geht ab als wenn es
selbstverständlich wä und die Leute
haben mitgesungen ich glaube
ja was soll man noch dazu sagen ich weiß
es nicht es ist es ist einfach so
passiert okay eine Monopolstellung die
wir da auch haben ne also das sagen wir
auch eine Monopolstellung es ist auch
wirklich es gibt ja so viele Rapper z.B
weil wir auch eigentlich aus dem HipHop
kommen Rappen es gibt ja so viele Rapper
die immer irgendwie versucht haben Club
hier zu machen und im Club zu
funktionieren und das hat bei uns
wirklich dann funktioniert und so und
man muss ja sagen wir waren schon auf
dem richtigen Weg bevor das zum großen
Pop Medienhype wurde dass Rapper diese
Dance Sachen machen jetzt timoy z.B mit
DJ Antoine der Song oder es gibt eine
ganze Menge so ein Zeug aus Snoop Dog
der auf einmal auf technobats rappt und
so und wir waren da schon ein bisschen
Vorreiter und auf Deutsch sind fast
sogar die einzigen es gibt noch so ein
paar andere aber Deich kindind ist jetzt
schon die man schon wieder was anderes
als wir das kann man nicht vergleichen
kann man nicht vergleichen ist schon was
anderes aber darf auch auf keiner Party
fehen also in
jedem gehört auch dazu muss man schon
sag gemischt mit das geht ab discoogo
und danach kommt das neue Album das ne
Album das neue albummikum 3 ja so
sieht's
aus fünf kommt auch noch okay super
vielen Dank cool danke auch danke auch
und die anderen partymusiker von denen
die zzen gesprochen haben deichin könnt
ihr jetzt im Interview sehen wo es auch
um Musik und die GEMA das leidige Thema
auf Youtube geht und empfehlen kann ich
ein anderes Fragenlotto nämlich das mit
Serda somunjo gibt's da etwa einen
cholerischen Anfall h nahe zuu bis dann
daan und äh angucken
natürlich